spot if I paid what is rumored he hasn't
said its what if I paid around about 100
mil for Joe Rogan and increased their
market cap by 5 billion how do you
listen to Spotify an Apple device so
like they don't care it doesn't really
matter what Spotify Deezer life like if
they get your own brilliant and when
you're making 10 billion in air pod
sales so you're listening to Joe Rogan
on Spotify on your Apple I've really
missed a miss an opportunity here Johnny
and you safe from propane fitness.com
what's happening what is happening you
well very good we've had an extended
sound check crispy now you guys started
shouting limericks at me down there down
the line it was very interesting it is
just because I am NOT the pheasant
plucker I'm only as mate and I'm
standing in for the pheasant plucker
because the pheasant look is late I had
no idea that that was what you were
gonna sound check I just asked you to
count to five that's like getting a six
nugget chicken nugget meal and finding
out that there's seven nuggets in it
that's exactly okay how do you feel
about you know when you have like a pack
of monstermunch this is a very light
year five problem and then at the bottom
you've got a ball of just pure seasoning
alright don't remember that I don't
think that never happened to you should
surely get it within like a Cornetto or
a flake 9900 or the chocolate just pure
chocolate yeah when it's over filled
with chocolate that's something that's
something else well what's another good
one is when you used to have ice gems
and then at the bottom corner of the
little ice gem packet there would just
be some gems oh sorry some ice you know
mean nice gem salad JIT why why would
you ever stop making that I don't think
they have I think they have a sharp
leader as well I never seen them yeah a
chocolate one you know how much time do
you spend in the confectionery aisle
though more time than you probably
expect really you don't have a massive
sweet tooth I do well use not indulge it
when we're out for dinner
there's a really good picture of
Johnny's meal from a few years ago that
we have on Instagram which was him at
the end of the day realizing that he's
got a certain ratio of macros to makeup
and couldn't make it up through normal
means and so it's what looks like a pot
of yogurt with jelly tots in but in fact
the perspective is wrong and it's
actually a kilo of yogurt with a multi
bag of fruit pastels in it is it not the
double or did you not used to do stuff
with double deckers as well yeah
Johnny can you give me another like just
a tiny little twist on your game bro
just a little bit just a little bit
chefs moved his mic in so he's a little
bit now anyway we are taught that
two-minute intro we are doing another
catch-up episode just catch in the
fudgey up finding out what's been going
on number one on the list the biggest
news in the world apart from the
pandemic that's running right outside
Joe Rogan moving to Spotify so anybody
who doesn't know what's going on Joe
Rogan has signed an exclusive long year
deal multi-year deal probably three or
four years with Spotify the rumored
amount was a hundred mil now I don't
know if that's 100 mil a year or a
hundred mil total but either way it's a
significant amount of money it's the
largest amount of money that a podcast
has ever been paid for a platform
exclusive and I think that there's
probably quite a lot of implications for
what's going on here so I'll give you a
little bit of background Rogen announces
that he's moving the entire podcast to
Spotify every old episode will remain on
YouTube on Apple podcasts stitcher
wherever else you tuned in but from the
end of the year it will be new episodes
will only exist on Spotify and Spotify
going to create a video platform
exclusive like create a video hosting
platform in the Joe well I'm presuming
they will roll it out thereafter but
like on Apple podcasts at the moment you
can actually create video podcasts Brian
Rose breakdancing inside well while we
we did it ages ago but it Rams your your
allowance your storage up here on your
your hosting platform so yeah spot if I
say that they're going to do that Oliver
oguns old stuff but this means no more
YouTube it means no more Apple podcasts
he will continue to upload some clips to
YouTube on the JRE clips channel which
is good I guess for him for the
searchability virality people
discovering the podcast but full
episodes the only place that you can get
them for presumably the next couple of
years at the very least is going to be
Spotify that's audio and video and then
the he announced that the Spotify share
price closed eight percent up that night
and then the next day did another ten
percent
so Spotify paid what he's rumored he
hasn't said it's what if I paid around
about 100 mil for Joe Rogan and increase
their market cap by five billion that's
a five thousand times return five good
move 500 550 yeah hundred million yes or
no best not whatever weight because it's
America million and and UK billion as
well right
because Imperial measurements isn't it
yeah I know how many is it can you tell
me that old money please does it in
stone yeah seventeen pounds and four
ounces so yet Rogen's made this move 100
million to increase your market cap by
five billion no matter how many times
that is I know that's a good deal some
of the other interesting things
Spotify pledged to spend five hundred
mil on podcast acquisitions during 2020
now the big chunk of that's gone on
Rogen but I don't know what you guys
know that they bought anchor last year
uncle ever without you I can't Yankel
Everett I am Cal ever it in anchor like
the butter manufacturer yes and them
they bought every business that has the
name anchored now every what is uncle
so anchor is a podcast hosting platform
it's one of these new ones so you guys
LUN Lipson know you're on blueberry
podcast path
the one that no one uses that it always
breaks or not all of WordPress uses
that's never broken that's a lie don't
lie anyway so it's similar to that but
there's this new wave of podcast hosting
platform like anchor and what they allow
you to do is actually create and edit
your podcasts in the web app so it's
like Garage Band integrated into so you
upload your single file you can clip
stuff you can add in intros outros
upload your media library and stuff like
that see that there's a lot of
low-hanging fruit for that and it's it's
mad that it's taken this long given
where we are in the curve with podcasts
for something like that to come along
because I think this that there's a lot
of stuff related to the the Spotify Joe
Rogan take over that is pointed out like
how how many gaps there are in like
really obvious gaps that you could
easily take over I've got I got some
cool stuff for you guys to think about
now I can't wait to hear your thoughts
on this and also everybody that's
listening I want to hear what you think
this is a big move we are myself Joanie
and Yusuf are very interested in terms
of both creators and consumers in the
podcasting space so it's like it is the
biggest news that's probably going to
happen for quite a while
Patrick Pat Davies from value tainment
reckons that within the next five years
we will see a 1 billion dollar podcaster
deal which probably doesn't seem too
ridiculous considering that Rogen's
already managed to get a million sorry a
hundred million for his deal
so yeah what you get with these sorts of
hosting platforms like anchor fm
so to not get to sort of nerdy into it
currently what most podcast use is the
RSS feed so you upload a file and then
that distributes to wherever you're
listening to this so it distributes to
Apple podcasts and stitcher and so
Spotify actually is one of those but the
way that it works is it has a single
file which is hosted which is unmovable
and unchanging and then that gets sent
out it's a syndicated to all of these
different platforms right they're just
an RSS a glorified RSS reader the what
Spotify is intending on doing now that
it's got anchor as this create an curl
ever while
now that it's got that as its creation
platform they have started to introduce
dynamically targeted ads mid-roll during
podcasts so if you ever listen to true
Jordy this is why I [ __ ] hate and
this is a big implication for people
that listen to podcasts right listen a
true Jordy and halfway through
they'll just be an advert for WH Smiths
read by some fella like studio-quality
like have you subscribed to your most
recent edition of gardening world well
why don't you head over to WH Smiths
today and get five pounds off with the
codes true Jordan Civ man so this is
modified this just can interrupt
anyone's podcast and put in their own
advert no technically no so what will
happen and this is what I think will
happen with Rogan Rogan was making
somewhere between not including YouTube
ad revenue he was making somewhere
between 50 grand and 150 grand per
episode on his based on his CPM he does
about 150 million downloads per month
he'll have discounts on the long term
deals people that's been with him for
years like stamps comic being with him
for seven years on it won't pay as much
because he's a partner there etc etc
Busch Kashyap has been with him for
forever yeah I think Squarespace as well
or like Wix or something so what will
happen
I don't think Rogan will be doing any
more pre-roll podcast ads I don't think
he'll need to spot if I might have even
stipulated that he's not allowed to as a
part of this deal but what you will
potentially start to see if you're not
on Spotify Premium is that you will be
targeted with dynamic ads put mid-roll
into the podcast and what this means is
that we're moving from I saw this
analogy online and this is kind of a bit
I wanted to give over to you guys I saw
this analogy on the on the internet
where someone said podcasting at the
moment feels like the Internet in the
early 2000s before everything was
syndicated before there was Google
targeting and tracking pixels and
Facebook ads and retargeting and all
this sort of stuff where people were
just saying that looks like the sort of
site or podcast that my audience listens
to because being honest like
modern wisdom is now venturing into this
world we've got every episode now has
got a sold-out pre-roll ad and I'm very
fortunate some of the partners I work
with a Laker protein works fit book
tailored athlete Reebok you know like
huge surf shark PPR big companies that
are prepared to pay like great money to
be there but they're just looking at me
and going yeah yeah you you look you
look like yeah yeah young people that's
what young people like the young people
but that's not like that's not actually
how targeting works and that's not what
advertisers won like using a [ __ ]
discount code to track sales like what
would you say Johnny if I was like are
their most sophisticated format we have
here is that someone's got to enter this
particular bit of text well the work the
worst thing about it is that like you're
relying on the person reading out an
advert for you you know you're spending
all this money and then the way that's
delivered is you basically send someone
a text file they have to read at the
start the podcast you think well that's
like is that hmm
that being said I think that so there's
two types of ads there's dynamic and is
baked in so they're baked in ads the
post host read pre-rolls
are more expensive and that's because
making the host put it in their own
words converts better so me saying this
is what I like about the protein works
because I do this is why I enjoy the
tailored athlete this is why Surf Shack
VPN gets you access to Netflix is
library or what I use it for bridges the
gap between yeah it's not so jarring not
just a dude talking about WH Smith just
like whoa what's that the the difficulty
is that when someone's heard an advert
or even like a baked in thing as you as
you said and it's like oh remember to go
to Tim blog forward slash wealthfront
forward slash Tim forward slash 500 and
I'm driving I'm not gonna remember that
URL to go and remember whatever
butchered it but like to come home and
also not not only remember the URL but
also remember that you even wanted to go
and check that out whereas if you're on
a platform you know like you're on
Instagram you'll be interrupted by an
advert and you
and click on it straight away and
probably leave the platform if it's
something you what if I might have not
only a dynamic ad they get put in at
particular sections throughout the
podcast but then that ad might be
matched with some sort of visual link
that's what they just heard on I think
I'm the one you only one out of the
three of us that's still on Spotify the
only person in the world that doesn't
pay for Spotify yeah you'll have a
you'll have a third-party app I imagine
that blocks the other spot if free yeah
there we go do you know why I know that
it's because I have just finished the
life hacks Volume one ultimate life
hacks list
oh that's a few hundred life every life
act that we've ever featured so anything
that you do now I know it because I've
had to go back through and write a
little little description of what it is
you get release radar you sir yeah it's
good what is that what's really great
it's a curated playlists of stuff that
you might like it's actually it's one of
the most impressive things about machine
learning and kind of algorithms that
I've found because like such a high
proportion of the songs in release radar
I really like and it's not just like oh
you like young people music so I'll put
some of the young people stuff in it
it's like it's really carefully done
yeah I'd like a podcast release radar
well I could discover weekly like okay
usually it's a it's a selection so if
you think about like I know there's
maybe a list of podcasts at the moment
people maybe own listen to if you take
it forward five years people probably
listen to even more podcasts you got a
curated list of like here are the most
popular releases from the podcast you
typically listen to you in a list if you
just kind of work through as a playlist
but the problem is is Johnny I need you
to put more gain unbroke if that's
alright
the problem is that at the moment as a
advertiser or even as a podcast Allah I
don't really know who listens to this
show I have an idea of who listens to
the show based on the Instagram DMS I
can look at the YouTube demos because
they go quite in-depth because you got
to sign up with your full account gender
blah blah blah location but really you
just like shooting blind and just hoping
that the content lands with people and
from a targeting perspective that's
obviously quite a big deal
so yeah I just think I was originally
kind of like ah god it's a big change I
don't listen to podcasts on Spotify I
prefer Apple podcasts because it's
native because it's very very smooth
also losing YouTube and losing the
youtube comment on episodes that I don't
comment ever but I enjoy looking at what
goes on and I like to hear how it lands
with other people but you know if
Spotify see that and they're able to
then create a platform which kind of
reflects what's gone on there I guess
that could be quite fun yeah I the more
I think about I think the thing I was
most sad about was the video loss of
video my mic okay now by the way lovely
but the loss of like cuz I quite like so
for example at the latest Elon Musk Joe
Rogan podcast I got I've watched the
video one I haven't watch the whole
thing but I'm watching the video rather
than listening to it and for some reason
God does this mean that you can only
watch the video on Spotify platform or
that you have to pay a premium Joe Rogan
subscription to see know so you will you
will be able to watch or listen to Joe
Rogan for free on Spotify whether you
have Spotify through your premium
however I think if you don't have
Spotify Premium you will be hit with
dynamic mid-roll ads sure so I I heard
rumors that the whole podcast was going
to become a premium one but I don't
think that would be in his in his
announcement about he says he stipulates
that's not what's happening right it's
yeah and it's I think from his
perspective like he's getting a hundred
million I don't think he's thought of
this as a big like a strategic move of
the war between iTunes and Spotify and
Netflix me I think he's just been like
yeah a hundred million just does that
now exceed the value of what I would
expect to gain from continue because
like at the moment his revenue model is
hinged on production whereas it sounds
like with Spotify like as long as you
are exclusive to us and continue just
enjoying like doing what you probably
enjoy doing most in your life then
here's 100 million well regardless of
what you listen on I know you use if
you've kind of moved through a few
different podcasting apps but me and
Johnny uses Apple
because no matter what it is that you
listen on now you have to listen on
Spotify so it's quite a big signal from
them to just say look this is the size
of our penis
now penis is so large we've taken the
biggest podcaster on the planet not only
if we because he was he wasn't even on
Spotify so if you go on to Spotify now
and search Joe Rogan he hasn't got a
single episode except for the new
trailer which is like just a audio
version of the announcement that you
made on on Instagram and like for them
to say not only gone from zero to
exclusive yes multiply yeah and that is
a huge move now from my side again
thinking about the fact that we're
starting to slowly monetize this podcast
and dealing with partners that I really
love like Joe's just told the world how
much value is in podcasting and
podcasters like every podcaster that's
listening whatever yours currently
charging for your CPM like treble it
because Rogen's just work just said that
he's worth a hundred million and made
Spotify five billion in two days it's a
very smart move from Spotify it's very
much so clever I wonder whether Apple
did a counter bid or if they were just
like Oh bollocks like we've just lost
Joe I can't see I can't see them doing
it man I could see I could see him going
to YouTube speaking to Google and saying
look and potentially leave him what do
you want to do but he keeps on getting
censored on there so for instance he
can't stream other people's content you
know he's always like Jamie don't put
that up we'll get to how Jamie's always
like don't put that up we'll get taken
down and yeah youtuber brutal and and
they just don't care cuz even Joe Rogan
is just such a small proportion of their
total traffic they just like whatever
yeah
but I'm I'm surprised about Apple not
putting in a not throwing the height in
that ring because so I just got a year
of Apple TV for free
and Johnny's mentioned how they've
really like thrown in some really
high-profile actors and just plowed
budget into their stuff to really try
and like catch up with Netflix and with
Amazon TV I was a called Amazon Prime TV
or something like so they're really
aggressively diving into these spaces
and for them to just lose
exclusively to Spotify when there's this
constant you know the back-and-forth
court cases that Spotify and Apple have
where they wouldn't allow Siri and stuff
like that yeah so because like how do
you listen to Spotify you have to open
the app you can't just be like one what
though an Apple device so like they
don't care yes like like when you Elena
Marshall they're spotify means it
doesn't really matter what Spotify do
like if they get your own brilliant and
when you're making what was the figure I
sent you ten billion in whatever that's
oh yeah yeah in air pod sales maze wrap
wrap your head around that face so
you're listening to Joe Rogan on Spotify
on your life I really missed missed an
opportunity here and one day they could
just be like oh sorry Spotify is broken
on up all my phone's now oh what a shame
the guy the guy sat in there in the
rocking chair in the corner smoking me
cigar while everyone else has an
argument isn't it it's just like like
wins regardless yeah and then he just he
just as they just as this he just goes
like that and then his driver comes over
and then he leaves just puts his hand in
the air just one finger in the air
raises it and then he departs and
everyone knows when he leaves the entire
building and everyone else disappears
conversations conversations over exactly
game game is over
okay so that's that's my thoughts on
Rogan man like I was real hesitant when
it first happened and I put a story up
that got I don't think I've ever had so
many replies like hundreds of replies to
me being sad about Joe Rogan changing
main reason I was sad was because he
promised he'd never go platform
exclusive on the show and like people's
priorities change I get that I just hope
that it doesn't damage the quality of
the content you know cuz he's my sort of
podcasting role model he's the person
that I've taken the most inspiration
from he's who I listen to the most
consistently across time and I just
don't want the show to be to be damaged
you know that people don't listen to him
because of the [ __ ] platform they
don't listen to him because of the ads
they listen to him because of the
quality of the content and if this
enables him to put out better content
then I'm happy to pay the price
a little bit more friction of having to
use Spotify yeah
well it's it's kind of bit it's behavior
change isn't it as a as a consumer of
the information cuz sit like something
I've noticed over the past two years my
my YouTube uses usage has gone up like I
would never ever really like sat and
watched a youtube video before but there
are things now that I'll happily sit and
watch like a 10 15 20 minute video what
like and I think I can see myself I
don't use Spotify for podcasting at the
moment or listening to podcast but why
delay goes by like you sports fine fine
why not like what what what's the tech
friction that's stopping you think you
just there it's just there like the UI
like it's not as it's not as easy to
navigate between podcasts you know how
to get on to podcasts on Spotify there's
a like it's in the arse end of your
library in the back end of the tabs like
if I podcasts up so I think this would
be a good thing for the UI as well
because if people start flocking to it
there's gonna be pressure on their
development team to make it more user
friendly because if like and considering
how simple these apps are all to use if
you're still not wanting to use it
because of that they're gonna have to
make a change otherwise like people
scale as well billions of people using
these apps imagine the support tickets
it doesn't even bear thinking about does
it
I imagine it was like Apple have a
support inbox they've just got a team of
Irish geniuses that she called Jeannie I
that call you back they do they love a
phone call don't know they just want to
get you off I'll tell you what so I'm
I'm gonna start as I keep on teasing out
and his Greg McHugh and red peeled me on
my own show about blogging I'm gonna
start writing and I spoke to medium so I
went hunt this is so [ __ ] mad right I
went on to medium to register Chris will
X just my social handle I'm gonna go on
there went on tried to register it this
username is not available
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] has someone taken my
you like no one else wants that it's
very specific went on searched for Oh
for as at hang on so Weiser a 404 error
if I
what medium calm / Chris relaxing
emailed them asked for a support ticket
within 12 hours have come back to me and
said actually because we're owned by
Twitter when we started medium we
registered every verified Twitter's
handle on me so that it was reserved for
that person I can see that your Twitter
account is linked to your medium account
would you like me to change that handle
over for you I was like [ __ ] yes bro
how cool is that all right so they're
owned by twitter twitter bought medium
about four or five years ago i love when
you just hear about like oh yeah uber
bought KFC and facebook what's happening
like so the telegram have bought or have
created their own version of medium
which is really interesting but it's all
obviously like blockchain verified and
like super tech nerdy basically have you
been obviously we're doing have you been
on a signal speed voice messages ah it's
the perfect feature signal have you been
on signal so that's like super secure is
the signals another step up from
telegram i like hit men no no so that's
wicker okay we heard of wicker WIC k WIC
chaos so you can't have messages that
don't delete after five days on wicker
you can't take you can't take
screenshots no one uses their own that
the real name you have to have face ID
to even access the app you can't turn it
off like May it's like what's the
incentive of the person who's created
that like let's make something where
everyone puts their really top-secret
stuff in and we'll just tell them and
gets deleted like if I was gonna harvest
people's data I'd go to that place
that's who I'd be it's what Edward
Snowden suggested people use for
messaging you know if you're in some war
torn country and you want to get your
words organized a freedom rally or
whatever supposed to do supposed to do
on on wicker yeah so if you were a
government and you wanted to create an
app that might warn you about uprisings
might it look something like Wicca
probably yeah
probably probably would here I don't
know my that medium thing I've
that writing on medium as well through
the mobile app and now this I know is
it's the total catastrophe but I just
wait to see what the what the writing
process was like man it's so good like I
I'm gonna guess both of you will have
the app yeah no it's not got the iPhone
up it's worth it's worth just
downloading it just for like to have a
play around on your next break or
whatever and anyone that's got medium on
the phone
just press the thing in the middle at
the bottom which is like to create the
writing experience is so beautiful it's
simplest thing in the world I was just
like oh you can just tell it to made by
Twitter you know it's already a losing
game if you're writing a blog post on
your phone yeah like but if you were I'm
like like you're gonna get a put a hook
for a hand as well so man who look like
Captain Hook and a Captain Hook um look
you you're gonna get a plus sized phone
next time is that right do you say that
SEF you were considering getting the
bigger screen version oh no sir the
smaller one smaller one that was it
no but next time did you not say you
were gonna afraid and get the bigger
well I'll get the iPhone 12 but whatever
that is just the one with the best
camera I don't care about screens well I
prefer a smaller screen however you know
what's really annoying since I've gone
from this is such a first world problem
like this is like hitting me
iPhone 11 slightly bigger than iPhone 11
probe I gave my mum the iPhone 11 got
the iPhone 11 Pro which is this one 3
cameras yeah yeah yeah so that that's it
just swapped it over she needed a new
phone so did your hand so you bought
another handset housing ended like a
three-way switch you but it's because
it's like slightly slightly smaller it
used to be that in scrub pockets the
iPhone 11 like pushes it out and keeps
it stable whereas now because it's just
got a little bit of leeway every time
you bend over or flexi hips or anything
it falls out rattling around and they're
just covered in co vid just all over the
phone
here I are great that's so full it's
awful so right okay we've talked about
Rogan we've talked about how cool medium
is what's been going on in your lives
what we what we catching up about
I made a list of things I made a list of
things this is like lightly things three
things that have happened in my life and
I'm joking 101 not I'm not very
interesting but that doesn't matter I'm
gonna find him interesting well we'll
see we will see I have been
experimenting with morning pages has
anybody ever done that before by June
Cameron
like the method of morning pee you know
he was on this boy who's on the podcast
on Friday is it is it the lady Hugh
Julian Cameron five million books sold
translated into 140 languages Martin
Scorsese is the testimonial on the
inside cover of her book Judy we can ask
you can ask her about it at the artists
way the artists way that's where morning
pages is from yeah yeah so I've bought
it and I'm using every day Chris should
we should we drop off we'll have a chat
about what he just said and then we can
we can come back yeah I don't know I
just I just thought it might upset Chris
because he bought me a really nice copy
of the five minute six minute diary and
it's just been undertaken in my defence
in my defense under your defense I
didn't buy you it the response or the
podcast and I got it for free so still
it was a heartfelt gift and it was
probably a task for you inside a six
minute diary to give him to give you
Soph a copy of the six movie very clever
isn't it
it started reading it and was like heart
disease this is actually really well
researched obviously you had like enough
momentum to overcome 30 pages of inertia
but you don't start writing until page
60 and he hasn't got another amount of
momentum you've got to be caught in the
like I think if you don't it's it's like
someone who
she's a magician do a trick you're just
the entire time thinks it's fake
yeah do you know and I mean like doesn't
matter how good it is like no it wasn't
it was up your sleeve it was an issue
and you just I think you just look at it
as like it is a physical book but I have
to use in the morning to write down
three things that I'm happy about so I
this may affect your explicit rating and
if so I'm very sorry but my flatmate the
other like a couple of years ago was
like Yousaf you come across as such a
kind lovely compassionate nice guy but
deep down you're just an intolerant [ __ ]
yeah I can't really disagree with that
it's because it's it connect to well
it's the architecture of a Scooby
problem isn't the problem else Cobb yeah
okay so morning pages you've never
Johnny have you artists way creative
process are you feeling more creative so
I don't I didn't I wasn't using it for
that reason I I'll tell you how I heard
about it so we interviewed a guy called
Ali Abdul I think I'm probably
mispronouncing his name he's a junior
doctor with a huge YouTube channel he's
a lot about makes a lot of videos about
kind of productivity and that sort of
thing he linked to a Tim Ferriss podcast
where Tim Ferriss talks about mourning
pages as a style of joining journaling
and it's this thing that he recommends
of like step one get everything like my
it's like monkey mind out down on paper
before you move into planning or like
coming up with a plan the theory being
if you sit down like journal or plan
your day but you're in like default
setting in your OS you'll just default
to like negative planning seeing
downsides of things and being reactive
rather than proactive so what what I
from to be honest is not very many
resources so I'm looking forward to this
podcast from googling it and looking on
YouTube there's a lot of like fairly
average apart from Tim's video fairly
average guides on how to do it but when
I suppose when it but when you boil it
down you open a book and you just write
whatever you was kind of on your mind
for three pages by hand and you stop
thinking oh this never note but like
people I think there's an analogy of
like that's like saying I'm stressed so
the way I'm gonna deal with stress is
like drive 100 miles an hour drink loads
of coffee like
the idea is you're slowing it down yeah
so yet by writing you have to slow the
process down so you do that
Amish approach isn't it it's the reason
that the Amish are like [ __ ] touted
as productivity gurus because they just
have to write everything we move a
little bit slower than most people you
know and it's always filmed as always
like cuts to a wide shot of them on the
back of the cart behind the man riding
on top of the horse we we like to move a
little slower here [ __ ] hell mate
yeah you talk slower as well so I've
never seen that reference at all Chris
so I just was wondering that whether you
are okay it's encounter ports Bachmann
saying cause it shows how much I pay
attention but yeah so that and then into
kind of a second journaling practice
which would be like planning planning my
day I've been doing it long enough to to
a certain thing say anything negative or
positive about it but it does feel quite
it does feel like you're kind of
lighting a bit of the air out a little
bit you know like you kind of do it and
you're like ah ah feels a bit better I
don't really know why but like you kind
of wake up and there's like stuff you
want to just then it kind of I think
that's I think that's really cold the
only the only challenge is going to be
that like it
writing handwriting three pages even at
like a five must take what 15 minutes so
full disclosure I've been doing like a
page in a bit so like I'll frankly like
to write three pages and maybe this is
an error to write three pages I'd have
to almost like sit and focus stuff than
fall say about so page and a half
probably takes like five ten minutes and
like a little more skill moleskin thing
a five but imagine how cool I know it
goes against the fact you go write by
hand but how cool would it be if you
could just dictate it on your morning
walk you know yeah thoughts come up to
it to be honest that's probably that's
probably just as good I think it's your
if you're like getting a laptop out and
typing it it does defeat the point a
little bit I think well you want to be
the point is that you just want low
stimulus focus on yeah it's going on
okay doesn't John that's a pretty cool
thing to excited do man and I'd timely
given that Julie is coming on the
podcast
yes weak man you know this woman five
million bucks she'll be by far the best
selling author I've ever had like she
pisses all over Robert Greene that is so
mad I've only heard of it because of Tim
Ferriss 1992 it came out right not well
that might be why would that's done some
volume up G bro rice 1992 she's written
40 books and like almost all of them
including the ones about prayer a
bestsellers mental a so I'm like set a
message to my mom about this morning cuz
mom's doing a lot more right head
drawing and I was like mom I got this
lady on this junior camera lady and she
used to go out with or she was married
to like some insane director as well
that's some top top level not Martin
Scorsese some top top level director as
well anyway mu airs scope what you been
doing anything morning stuff so I've set
an automated script on Mac - just keep
Wi-Fi off until 10:00 a.m. so that means
that when I wake up Wi-Fi is already off
I don't need to like to do that
admittedly there's been a lot of
emergencies recently where we've had to
have to undo that definitely tethering
it to your phone yeah yeah but yeah so I
did long it's not on a similar vein of
like creating a bit of space in the
morning because I think and luckily
we're in privileged position to wake up
and be so passionate about what we're
doing but you are just like pulling at
the reins to try and get started with
what you're doing but it's very easy
than to just get pulled off into either
the agenda of your yeah
urgent inbox or whatever is the first
task to come up and not actually to step
back and look strategically or what
you're doing so whatever is like just
interject with an analogy you know that
you know on Family Guy where he keeps
running into the chicken you know what I
mean yeah I guess people always like he
like he's like that's the chicken behind
the car and then for five minutes
there's a fight sequence it's really
elaborate that's how most of my days
feel every more like start off with a
plan and chicken just right I mean I
think particularly this year has been
like that so much
and you know just because we've got more
demands on on us in general and so yeah
we're looking where we're hiring out now
we're doing a lot more in terms of
spreading that load but I've realized
that out of the productivity principles
of capture review and do I'm very good
at capture and do but terrible at review
know me too and that's where things
start to tack because you end up doing a
lot and capturing a lot but it's just
yeah the reason I think that you do that
is because of the illusion of progress
right
you're like capturing feels like doing
something doing is doing something by
definition but reviewing just feels like
our I can get by without reviewing
therefore I can do more doing thus yes
precisely I can do more doing exactly
like reviews gonna take me 90 minutes I
don't have time for that when actually
you don't what you don't have time for
is 90 minutes of doing the wrong things
yeah well I mean this this hits the nail
on the head so I took Benjamin Hardy PhD
the number one writer on all of medium
was on the podcast this week although
the episode will come out in future
because this is coming out now I
apologize for the the Contra logical way
that podcast world works but um he
gifted me his genius blogging course
which is basically how do you get
400,000 email subscribers from just
blogging which he did in the space of
three years he's a monster that's crazy
and I did the whole course in a day
yesterday and like the main thing that
he does is write the headline iterate it
30 times write the subheadings as many
as you can then the article will fall
into place but for every minute that you
spend planning you save yourself ten
minutes of writing and there's so many
like implications about just life to do
with that you know like people that
don't have a morning routine they get up
and think that they can crack on with
their day more quickly because they
haven't prepped themselves in the
morning it's that yeah you like the
argument that people give against
meditating like I don't have time to
meditate but then it's like the
well this is the Dalai Lama quote isn't
it you should sit for half an hour a day
or if you don't have time you should sit
for an hour just like damn it so that
that's been the big lesson so since we
last caught up yeah why don't you just
use like so I imagine what you try and
block is email mainly or inbound
communication inbound communication you
know find you need the internet first
off to be sometimes but I think
sometimes that's a lie that I'm telling
myself and actually and it's so that
this actual this does bring me on to the
next thing which is that there's a lot
of stuff that I need to do now daily to
keep up with with the social media
strategy that we're following in a
minute that has to be done offline
because if it's done online you end up
with too many distractions and low
output Chris looks very confused I just
thought that the whole concept of your
guys's new social media strategy was
that it was done in advance and then and
then mostly automated half-laughs cuz
I've seen you replying to stuff more
like you replied to Thiago Forte saying
you don't need to like low-key pretend
that I'm one of your secret gurus the
thing is yeah it was like but just not
as sort of tweet I would have thought
that you guys are done so you trying to
do more automation plus more actual like
viral organic like oh yes it's so I
think you have to have a combination
because the platform wants you to play
the game as it's intended to be played
and so if you are always doing twee
threads it's not really hard to it as
intended to be you know it's meant to be
hundred and forty characters so and if
you always share dealing stuff again
it's it's don't get you're not
interacting are you you're just yeah
broadcasting and if you know if you're
not if you're taking people off platform
a lot it's also not ideal so it does
need it I think like I see it is the
embers are the the sheduled posts and
then you go in the strategic times of
the day and you book respond or you do
Instagram stories or or whatever so
creating that content in bulk I think
has to be done offline and just sit down
in the same way that you write a blog
posts you need to write a lot of tweets
so that's
that's been my main shift at the minute
and it seems to be working like the
propane Fitness Twitter have a look at
it on there we've we've just been it's
just quite a nice platform once you get
out of the weird corners of where
everyone's just flexing about their
Lamborghinis and following a big chunk
of people anyone that mentions coffee or
cold showers in their tweets or like
7-figure all that would be that would be
joy if you had a toilet Jones listen
yeah but it's so it's precisely that I
don't have a Twitter I'm too busy
drinking coffee having cold showers yeah
those are the real those are the real
cold exposure [ __ ] the ones who
were so cold the thing on even is
Micah's yes I'm just in my brain stem so
I can't wait Twitter's into the when are
you gonna get wim HOF on the podcast
Chris our [ __ ] knows man I met a girl
who works at the School of Life
shoutouts Janel little Matt girl he
works at the school of life and their
Christmas she told me this story man
their Christmas party organized by Alain
de Botton who is he's like owner and CEO
as well I didn't realize he's he's like
everything to that company um he
organized and she was telling me it's
just like a normal girl not really into
sort of self development or whatever and
was just a so he organized this
Christmas party and this guy turned up
and he had a beard and he made us do
loads of breathing I was like hang on a
second can I just get a photo op of a
man with a beard who does some breathing
and can you tell me if that's him please
and she said well they say you can do
but I fell asleep three minutes into
this like studio group work so that you
got got them all to lie down on yoga
mats doesn't maybe 20 people and so I'm
like okay can you text someone who
didn't fall asleep please and ask them
if it the man that gave you small group
coaching was wim HOF texted them reply
came back yes it was I was like you
[ __ ] fell asleep to the number one
breath coach on the planet she's like
yeah yeah well I was a bit hung Oh
we were going on a night out that night
and this I was thinking oh like
someone's parked a Ferrari in your back
garden and you're like oh that's a nice
new garden shed and you start like
putting your spades in it and yeah it's
it's been it's been an all right shed
it's a bit bit cramped but you know it
does the job he did it he's done a new
you know they have you both seen the
vice documentary with him on I imagine
you both have yeah quite a while is why
is quite old he's done another one with
a YouTube channel they're very well
known YouTube channel known for like
discomfort and stuff so he just puts
them straight into a nice cold river
with very little prep so I normally it's
like three days of breath work building
up your called exposure it was like this
can be done with just liberating and
puts them straight into ten minutes of
an ice-cold River in like the minute ol
one guys clearly like right on the right
on the limit he's like such looking
concerned and women's just going swims
in with them is he swims in with them
just not fazed and these guys who like
find discomfort for a lip for a living
and document it struggling so mad have
either of you guys heard of Connor
Murphy yes so he is a youtuber that does
a lot of quite vapid videos that are
just him going round a bit called like
shirtless prank or whatever so he's in
like a fleece with some padding and then
he's like he's wearing glasses and he's
like go to these groups of girls and
he's like hey so here's a picture of
this guy like what would you pump or
dump but like and they're like I would
pump in that and he's like okay well
he's actually here right now and they're
like what no he's not and he's like yeah
if you just stare close your any takes
off his glasses and he likely he's
topless it but it's just loads of that
but just repeat it so it's quite like
[Music]
silly YouTube channel and he's been even
posting that stuff for ages like
prolific with it and over the last three
weeks I fully recommend if you haven't
heard of this go and check this out cuz
it's I mean it's quite it's quite
heartbreaking really
but maybe three weeks ago he's clearly
having a psychotic break maybe taken
ayahuasca
based on some of the things that he said
and his videos have just changed
entirely to enlightening my friend
enlightening my manager enlightening my
parents there's just a zoom call of him
crying talking absolute nonsense like I
think the guy needs help but like people
are commenting being like not being able
to take his shirt off in public during
quarantines really got to kind of it was
like baby doesn't need help maybe maybe
he is the arbiter of wisdom yea he is
the help possibly have you considered
that you might just be enlightening
everyone with his is tears maybe I mean
this is that's one of the problems of
having a persona that tons and tons of
people have personas it's fine like if
you want to go through your life and not
do the introspective work and not
deprogram all of the bits and pieces
like how about it but when you then have
millions of youtube subscribers or
followers online you margin you leverage
you've like entered a position and then
leveraged it 50 hundred thousand ten
thousand times and you realize the
persona gets much much bigger than it
would have been and then the observers
and comment is on the downfall are also
like significant orders of magnitude
bigger that's so true it's leveraging
your trade isn't it like having a
psychotic breakdown is bad enough but
doing it with like 1.7 million
subscribers whatever hundred miles an
hour oh god and his parents are just
like Connor is are you joking with us
like I don't know what's going on I
would we're proud of you and then his
dad just how it's like a two-hour long
thing his dad just leaves halfway
through his visas camera on an empty
room she's psychedelics are one hell of
a drug pretty scary stuff the final boss
in the last level isn't it Johnny you
said you had you have three things one
of them was mono pages the other one's a
shite Minh oh go on
I just just erase something first did
you both see that you I must talk about
being read pilled
what I mean I don't know what you mean
by red pilled
was it the cancel cancel culture one no
the one way just talks about how he's
giving everything away oh yeah I'm
jogging away Wallisch in expect it do
you know who alex becker is Chris he's
the worst
empty house trillionaire he's got an
Internet yeah he's got a do YouTube
channel ways he's very he's quite
arrogant in the first segment of every
video but very aware of the fact that
he's arrogant in his latest video is
like can you believe that Elon Musk is
trying to mimic me like this is
unacceptable but anyway so Elon Musk's
giving everything away I just thought I
was interesting do you know what is
reason well you'll know it but Youssef
so this is the most Elan musk thing that
you could ever say about why so Rogan
psyche am i right in thinking that
you're selling like all your cars except
for a couple of Tesla's all your
possessions all your houses selling
everything that you own then Musk's like
yes so uh so why is that any pauses for
ages I don't know whether it's because
on the most recent Rogen he's like
feeling a little bit anxious last time
you tanked his stock price maybe he's
just in a weird space like from work or
whatever but he's he's not flowing at
the same rate he was allowed to even
that was like a trickle and this is just
like a single drip once every 30 seconds
he's so slow which is kind of nice it's
considered and cool and interesting if
you want that but it's not for a lot of
people are doubt it would have been
quite as engaging but anyway he um he's
so why he's selling all of you stuff and
he goes uh kind of I kind of see
possessions as an attack vector that's a
very long thing to say
yeah it's but it's because he's just
hard r2d2 and he wants to make sure that
he's 3d - that's what he wants next yeah
yeah Howie
he added like a 12 or something under
the name and that's related to a bomber
or a jet or something or a CIA secret
project or something yes it was that it
was the predecessor to the Blackbird or
whatever it was that's it the first
iteration of this how to get your son
bullied in suppose if you'd like
you're gonna have a jetpack anyway and
later a cyborg yeah the first one on
ours so were matter if you get bullied
on this that's right yeah but um when he
when Joe asks him about cuz he owns like
I it's been really interesting having a
kid because you you watch them learn and
you realized that actually like the
newer on that ever the of an AI is
really similar to a human brain and
suffer like my partner thinks Elon
that's a weird thing to say mate but at
the others time at the other side like
I've been thinking about that
conversation about AI since I listen to
it which is about a week ago or whatever
it came out cuz Joe's like why would he
want to mimic an AI I remember the exact
question it's like why isn't AI trying
to be like a human and then he lands
like well a like you take parts of it
but you don't make the exactly duplicate
it's like a plane doesn't fly like a
bird a submarine doesn't swim like a
fish you take like the underlying
principle and make it more efficient in
doing the thing that you're trying to
make it do I just think when I hear you
I must talk about AI he's so comfortable
with it about what it's obviously you
can but his his was it's like hearing
anyone that's an expert in anything that
he evidently has to do a lot of work to
take himself from where he is to down to
the level yeah he knows dived by forty
thousand feet in a desperate attempt to
use language which is even slightly
understandable to the cleverest people
that are listening and it's that's what
I think a lot of the work is that he's
conscious to the fact that he could talk
about like the synaptic properties of
myelin wrapping around like blah blah
but what he actually needs to say is
it's it's kind of a little bit like the
internet or like it's a little bit like
you know like he needs to everything's
and everything's an analogy that normal
people can can understand mmm he's just
such a first principles guy he's a
[ __ ] man
he's such a [ __ ] and the fact
that you've been thinking about his
conversation for this long shows that
it's I yeah maybe if there's ever
something that you hear at the time the
Alerus [ __ ] [ __ ] and it sticks with
you for a long time that means that the
person that said it is far smarter than
you are and you have then been forced to
reflect on it yeah to him it's
completely obvious
but that one you like yeah
either but he's an absolute badass
Saffir you been doing anything else any
other stuff been happening what's that
well you got in your hands look at Matt
stay what you sleeping things I got some
ice 20 earplugs
I saw the Instagram out for them this
morning did you you probably been
retargeted cuz so yeah I'm getting some
really good Instagram adverts at the
minute you know like they're awesome
like that is I was talking about this
yes the other day I'm coming around to
your idea Johnny that like you know
people know I don't want face but
knowing Martin or as I might well
actually if they get me cool stuff like
this you know the appetite you do know
that you two have the same Instagram
yeah I know that's what's most
impressive about it but you're like yeah
you both of your interests are quite
aligned like both of you would look at a
pair of titanium sleeping air plugs and
go yeah yeah the only difference between
me and Johnny is one Spade and ones
organic but like apart I thought one was
one was Arab and one was Aryan is that
not the difference well yeah
once syrian fire dry-roasted and I think
the ones it's one carbonate one Spade
and the other one tries to use art
credit vouchers you've got some earplugs
what are they so you know I was saying
on the last episode that my neighbours
have the loudest sex at all times of day
the guy is some kind of stallion going
out like 45 minutes at a time just like
ramen ahead but I can only assume it's
that it might they might be doing like
the Joe wicks daily Bosch furniture
around
but yeah perfect the titanium in the
center is meant to cut out base
frequencies and that they are pretty
silent
Wow so you know what worries me about
stuff like that is that someone's gonna
sneak up on me in the middle of the
night luckily I've got the few horn that
you guys got me and it's the perfect
weapon it's right next to visit it's got
such a weighted tip as well
I know Dean's got the same one man I
mask
Amazon that's got like a ring around it
that sits on your eyes safety they were
using eye mask well we covered this on a
life hacks episode did I talk about my
eye mask did I but not that's a bad
thing tell us again some people was just
so normally an eye mask is like presses
on your face and when you try and open
and close your eyes it obviously the eye
mask resists against the eyelid movement
so you become more aware of it you more
likely pull it off
this one has foam rings that lifts it
away from your eyes so your eyes are
free can move freely and then you
basically just feel like you're in a
dark room
it's quite a strange I'd have very good
I'd heard something to do with how much
dry your eyes are when you have an eye
mask which presses on your eyelids as
well because really any yeah any
moisture or whatever that's seeping
through your eyelids will get picked up
by Yusef to gone and got is that the
same one is that the exact one it's not
exactly is it very very similar
extremely something go put it on for a
sea surface Wow what is it what's the
light seepage like like can you still
see light around probably around the
bridge of your nose I imagine if I move
it down a bit than zero yeah that is
peak virgin isn't it pretty complete
well you know what's also people are
just either virgin or long-term
relationship yeah nowhere in between I
mean that's that's both me and you that
isn't it is that the velvet a velvet
finish
I can't hear it oh you can hear us use
them he's unplugged his headphones you
don't [ __ ] up Outland yeah so yeah and
once you sleep have you been alternating
tracking sleep quality on whoop I mask
no I mask yeah add the eye mask thing on
yeah I've also been a tell you about the
four Sigma Matic reishi elixir
let me try talking about that it's
mushroom something to do with what if
it's from forcing next set an alarm for
9 a.m. elixir know so it's it's I mean
to be honest it's lovely it's like a hot
chocolate but it's got mushroom in but
you can taste the mushroom just tastes
like an earthy hot chocolate that
I think it effect so I drink that and
then I meditate and then I go to bed I
think it causes low level like things to
happen in my visual field
well I meditate how soon after drinking
it do you meditate 10 minutes how long
does something take to go from mouth to
any area of the body which can absorb
whatever is just gone into your mouth
Yusef could be from instant to several
hours it may be it may not be that I
just think unless it's unless it's
literally going through the capillaries
of your mouth like so by golly it seems
unlikely that it's going completely
agree completely agree it's purely
anecdotal that I think that might be
what I've experienced I'm excited to try
that man I've I've been fuxing around
with some serious supplements recently
so jigsaw health that with a company
that Ben Greenfield advised for
magnesium supplement number one
magnesium supplement in America like
very X very expensive but not very
expensive they're like the premium
premium quality it's like buying the
best of anything I suppose when you
compare it with my proteins zma tablets
or whatever you know like anything's
gonna be expensive competitors is
exactly what I have yeah so this this
stuff they have mag srt which is slow
release you take through the day so you
take four of those three the day and
then they have mag sued on a night time
which is a pre bed drink like a tart
cherry sort of dray really really nice
but the volume of magnesium that I'm
getting in me is so high that I can't
even track the actual amount on whoop so
whoop maximum amount is 600 milligrams
and I'm well over that because of this
amount she'll eat she'll eat magnesium
chelate I can't remember I'm not sure so
that and then they make this adrenal
cocktail which is what's what shall I
mean is that this is that it's just the
the when you hear people when you get
into the world the magnesium world which
is bigger than you think a lot of people
talk about chelated a chelated form of
man
as being the best for pre-sleep which is
what is in this it's not easy it's
really legit so that plus I've got
finally managed to find a good CBD brand
and the most recent stuff that I've got
is 10,000 milligrams so the
concentrations in say it's like the most
viscous thing that you've ever seen so
that plus the mag srt plus this new mag
suit is I've just been [ __ ] her
because why not you've got nothing else
to do during lockdown that and then
adrenal cocktail in the morning also now
doing nad and nmn and resveratrol every
day interesting interesting impact on
mood interesting impact on training
output and other bits and pieces but
[ __ ] knows what's going on man you know
[ __ ] knows he's just in a video about
CBD ok actually he just asked what do
you what do you know about CBD well
received well so the full breakdowns on
are on the website but it just basically
is available on YouTube as well I'm
sorry on YouTube yep on the website so
the the framing of the question and
actually every time we're asked about
CBD people are like oh can you talk to
us about the benefits of CBD
alright well even in the question you've
you framed it is like you wanting it to
be beneficial and ultimately it's a
neurotransmitter that is gonna be that's
gonna have a wide range of function so I
just talked through the different the
data on mood sleep anxiety like all
these kind of these kind of effects and
it the the answer is really that it has
some effect for certain problems but
it's new we don't know a massive amount
about it and personally I would like I
don't think I've not had any personal
experience with it so I can't talk
anecdotally it's just some of the data
on it but to be honest I recorded it
over a year ago interests uploaded it
because someone was asking me about it
so I think we'll all have to go back and
watch the video to let me see let me see
if I can speak to the company that sent
this out basically each bottle is
over a hundred it's 110 pounds a bottle
of this stuff like twice the cbt
magnesium CBD the mag suit max suits
much more
what do you would you get is it a
relaxation benefit frequency Beauty yeah
looking the the problem is that because
I received everything at the same time
adrenal cocktail mag srt mag soothes and
yeah and that like I I have no way of
identifying what's happening that
pre-workout you gave me Chris like I've
not even touched it because it's
terrifying so yeah like blue raspberry
part that's that's a that's a nootropic
that's not a pre-workout it's an endless
endless and yeah it's that's something
that I want to give away to Johnny's
mate who just loves pre workouts and
that kind of thing is there's no beta
alanine in it there's no nitric oxide in
it there's a caffeine I mean what's that
gonna do grams other in in it really hot
what's the was it because I imagine
that's normally what you're most scared
of is the caffeine it's the caffeine but
there's loads of stuff in there that you
like huperzine a and all this stuff that
you just like stuff there's given
Pidgeon seizures and I think just
imagining what it must be like to be
burdened with this kind of knowledge
that you have you know off the top of
your head it's how it plays our reality
is you told us about the other day where
you found out it was a main ingredient
in a Febreze
dextrans yeah it just binds to all the
smell the cracked me up day is so when
you're in a hospital
obviously like you've got the standard
doses of stuff that you would give like
upper end of those doses you're like wow
that's a bit scary like I'd and
sometimes like we had a guy in a cardiac
arrhythmia the other day and he had very
low magnesium on his like serum
magnesium on his previous blood test and
we will should give him some replacement
I think it needs to be IV max dose so I
can't offer tough my has something like
500 and so week like I called the
cardiology registrar I was like I want
to give some you know if it's 500
milligrams okay like he's quite low and
he was like just slap into grams like
two grams like this is you know and it
says I'm like the the formulary like do
not give more than 500 milligrams and
you like okay you're the expert but when
when someone in their specialties like
I'd be fine just give four times the
maximum mass are in something so I know
someone that when they when to say D
when she gets like dodgy advice from
someone or they dismissive she's like
okay no problem I'll just document that
what's your full name and GMC number
okay thank you and isn't it the case
that and this is something that keeps on
being brought up by ben shapiro which
again man i'm not i'm not going to be a
Ben Shapiro fan for the rest of my life
I'm not gonna be like an avid listener
but [ __ ] me at the moment you're in
covered he's such a great wealth of
information bro honestly and the fact he
speaks at two times speed means you
don't need to put two times speed on
which is you know also also a good
benefit one of the things that he's
talking about at the moment is this
doctor foul Qi who's the guide its
guiding most of the epidemiology for
America being criticized for the fact
that he says that reopening is going to
increase deaths but there's a was it
perverse incentives going on here
because doctor foul Qi if he says that
doing something won't cause deaths and
then some deaths happen he [ __ ]
whereas if he always
wildly on the side of caution like no
one is ever going to string him up for
saying that people shouldn't do
something then they're not doing it
doesn't caused and the deaths don't go
you know it's a very good point like if
the economy collapses he can be like
well I was just given medical advice so
yeah also that's the thing that's the
thing the point is that virologists
epidemiologists public health experts
their job is not to get the economy
moving their job is to try and reduce
the number of infections they don't care
about the collateral damage because
that's not their specialty like the
specialty for i mean who is it is it an
economist or like I guess like an
industry yeah well just like all the
policymakers speaking of which did you
see Trump talk about inject was it
injecting disinfectant bleach basically
yeah so funny that's been kind of spun
in number times Shapiro again has gone
through that in fairly big detail and
this is the real insidious thing that's
happening most of the problems that were
caused by Trump talking about either
ingesting sunlight or this
hydroxychloroquine stuff which is now
shown to increase all cause mortality
because of cardiac arrhythmias yeah risk
of death yeah but most of the problems
that came about from that wasn't what he
said it was then the media taking what
he said extrapolating that out into were
saying to the guy's face people are
using people reading what they'd said
about what he'd said that wasn't what
he'd said and then when you take
something which is on the knife edge of
potentially being bad advice and like
use nefarious language to then push it
well well into the territory of bad
advice it's like that's your fault
that's not his fault
I mean you don't get me wrong if the guy
says some idiotic and reprehensible [ __ ]
every so often but you were the delivery
mechanism for this particular [ __ ]
social virus the trouble is most most
media outlets are profit driven and then
just need circulation views and
attention so right there in
they're incentive is not necessarily to
provide the best like most balanced most
researched piece of information which is
why something like that like attempt to
me like that somewhat I think one of the
journalists said to Trump while he was
saying it like people aren't tuning in
to these briefings to be given like
speculative this might work it's it's
like basic advice that you should be get
like advice to the to that is applicable
to everybody
reassuring you're on it you're doing the
right thing don't mention like maybe you
know you're looking into that aren't you
you're bleach works doesn't it you're
looking into that on you then like spins
the the scientist who's like um ya know
yeah and then like it's like if you give
the media some like a file a video file
where they can snip it and make it look
[ __ ]
like it cannot what I want it's still
kind of his the line the line between
that and just deep faking now is
becoming increasing yeah it's rude yeah
I thinking that it's the you know
there's a couple of videos of they've
labeled them as Karen's but I don't
think I don't think I need from actually
called current going round like the
states weren't one of them's like sign a
car and she's like she's protesting they
shouldn't have to wear a mask because
because it makes her sad that you can't
look at people's faces or something and
and someone else was like going around
telling people to take off their masks
in the in the street because they're
like it's all just a conspiracy and
actually like it's wearing the mask is
what's weakening us all and it's killing
our antibodies and and you're just like
it's so interesting seeing like how this
is playing out in different art ends of
America how unfortunate is it if you're
called Karen if you listen to if you're
listening to this and your name is Karen
and you're not a mental conspiracy
theorist I want to talk to the manager
please lady with like a mullet I'm I'm
really sorry for you because your name
Karen and Sharon have both been taken
and just run with to being the epitome
of their I want to talk to the manager
please yeah Lady Margaret as well sadly
yeah
Margaret Karadzic Aaron it's not a
really good clip I think it's from one
of you guys might send you where someone
was talking about a patient who was
complaining about not having that child
vaccinated and and they were kicking up
a person and the doctor said to them
have you ever considered that the
anti-vaxxer
was actually perpetuated by the Russians
to weaken the health of the US
population and he said like the
combination of these receivers
contradicting paradigms in the head just
exploded she's just like somewhere in
the countryside in a huge barn big farm
at the big farmers sucked leg and the
big father there's a guy on our
Instagram who you'll know who this is
yousef I imagine as soon as I'm not
going to say the name but a lot of his
content at the moment is very like this
is you know sheep Gobar like everybody's
doing this because the government wants
us to stay inside and it's all part of a
big and like it's just interesting when
you see stuff like that there's a lot of
there's a lot of thought gone into that
viewpoint like he's not it's not just
like it doesn't or doesn't seem a
sophisticated man mmm doesn't seem like
cast off like are this just isn't isn't
important like it's a very well formed
or it's a very well thought out view and
you think it like it's just a weird
thing to think about when they're going
as far as to say that the current virus
doesn't exist and like I mean obviously
fit like for me it's a bit different
because like it's like well just come to
work with me one day and like you can
kind of solve that yeah hold that belief
mm-hmm but yeah like the amount of it
but it's it I think this is where
emotion comes before rationality and so
you come to the conclusion first and
then with the emotion and then the brain
tries to create and form arguments to
support that notion rather than the
other way around
and we all do it to an extent but this
is like to the endgame if I don't like
being told what to do I think big
farmers behind it all and I'm gonna
create and find evidence to support that
again I think I've told you guys about
this that compensator II control
mechanism that Matthew sired had in the
times I tell you this on the last
episode okay this is like the fifth time
I've dropped it on the podcast
so sorry to everyone let's listen but
Johnny and Yusef obviously have a lot of
content to absorb that doesn't include
this podcast compensate we control is
the tendency for people in periods of
uncertainty to find meaning in things
which have no meaning so people that
given an uncertain medical diagnosis are
more likely to see patterns in
meaningless static than those that
aren't and this is replicated across a
number of different studies and at the
moment
Matthieu science thesis hypothesis is
that people would much sooner presume
that this global pandemic is due to the
plans of some maligned scientists than
the chance mutation of a silly little
microbe and having that paradigm in your
mind compensator II control explains so
much people just want to have a
narrative they want to personify what's
going on what's this so it is there's a
reason behind this it's like no
sometimes [ __ ] stuff just happens
because there is a chance that some [ __ ]
stuff will happen and this is the same
what you're talking about they're like
people who have slightly bizarre
worldviews that are incredibly
sophisticated is what I saw when I did
that evolution and dating episode with
Rob Henderson and this guy came in and
gave this [ __ ] thesis length comment
on YouTube about oh no sorry is when I
did the one with Chelsea Ferguson from
at my meetup VIP this big long thing
about how I was manipulating the female
dating market by still being single at
32 and that Chelsea was setting a
terrible example all this stuff it was
like just crawled straight out of 4chan
already ormita manipulating the female
dating market by being 32 in single yet
in I've tied up a bunch of preview he
was presuming that I tied up a series of
other girls relationship availabilities
throughout the period of my dating
history up until now by doing that I'd
taken time away from a man who would
have potentially got a look in had I not
have been with them that's ridiculous
assuming that that's assuming that the
women have no free choice and can't
decide what they want to do either one
of you if you want to be in a
relationship with someone that sports
because Chris is such a hunk which is
the bizarre thing is I literally
couldn't
[ __ ] pay for it in 2020 so like that
aside what I was surprised by was how -
how sophisticated it was he's got all
different acronyms using all these
different words ah this is it's because
of the sexual market value crossover
point of the of the the peaks state this
of childhood epiphany I'm not there is
an entire body of work
underpinning what you're talking about
at the moment and the sophistication is
scary it's like the same thing with flat
earthers it was like they had they'd
created ever increasingly elaborate
models to try and work out why the thing
was the thing that they thought it was
because it wasn't so it needed have you
seen I can't remember it was before
Copernicus's view about the heliocentric
geocentric version of the universe and
if you actually look at this it's at the
top of Chris sparks article that
Jordanaires loves about our increasing
complexity and if you look at the way
that they presumed the universe had
their solar system had to work there
were all of these crazy interweaving
like looping orbits that everything had
to explain the fact that sometimes
planets pass back and forth in opposite
directions so the reason that that
happens is because when you move quicker
than something circling around something
else you can actually see it go in a
different direction but they had from
above this net image of like what was
that thing you serve as a kid where
you'd draw not a Scalextric do you know
I mean gyroscope no jars yes but no it
was like it you put a gel pen on the end
and you've just run out of battery
haven't you use something when it's on
your mic you know yeah it's it's fine
anyway let's call that as the end of the
episode we didn't even get on a Boris's
announcement but it was [ __ ] [ __ ] it
was 45 minutes of confusing hyperbole
that didn't really explain what was
going on and I don't know wasn't work
then you do and if you shan't then you
can and if you get the bus then don't
but if you go outside don't they know
that don't go outside okay
but stay outside for as long as you want
you need to for unlimited time but but
not if you have to work and you
shouldn't go to work but don't take
public transport I mean take public
transport but wear a mask
[ __ ] off man honestly anyway boys thank
you so much why should people go they
want some macros or they want to pivot
to go to become an online coach propene
fitness calm for / modern wisdom if you
want to become an online coach or
transition existing services online and
then propene fitness.com forward slash
forward slash calculator if you'd like
some macros lovely everything will be
linked in the show notes below thank you
to everyone for tuning in I hope that
you enjoyed that little catch-up episode
I know that I do these timely ones are
really really fun and cool got any
questions comments or feedback you know
where to go just targus on twitter give
us a message on the leave a comment on
youtube whatever it might be so now
gentlemen thank you very much ok bye do
you speak see
[Music]
you